agents we've recovered five of the
hostages taken in the attack on the
White House but with each member of our
community we learn Natalia Sova is not
the murderous psychopath we assumed I
don't know if it's General Anderson's
influence over her organization or if
spending her life on the move is getting
to her but it appears that the black
task have adopted the true son's tactics
and are looking to shore up
infrastructure and build something what
that something is is too early to tell
without Vic as Mari says he knows her
organization he helped build it
agents if we want to rebuild the castle
and know what cover is really up to we
need to get Vic and unmask the
[Music]
asset Cindy melster was raised in a
household with strong military ties and
was the youngest of six siblings with
five older brothers Cindy was one of the
boys and developed a keen passion for
gaming following her enlistment in the
Army she found her Niche within the
National Guard as a drone pilot after
the outbreak she would join The Joint
Task Force and due to her Excellence she
would quickly be recruited by the
division in this position she would
assist agents and scouting various
locations warning the Agents of lurking
threats and potential
ambushes when the Russian scientist
fatali Treno emerged once again this
time on Coney Island Cindy maneuvered a
remote drone collaborating with the
division agents to orchestrate jtf
forces ensuring the successful location
and extraction of Treno in the face of
fierce resistance from the Black Tusk
she hacked into their mortars turning
their Weaponry against them following
the successful extraction of Treno by
the division agents Cindy identify the
remaining Black Tusk operators currently
Under Siege by the cleanness her
guidance directed the agents to the
heart of the amusement park allowing
them to neutralize all hostile units but
as the agents removed the last of the
opposing forces the Drone was suddenly
hacked by the rogue agent Aaron
kenina before the Drone was destroyed
kenina sent his message to the agents
claiming that he will continue to be one
step ahead of them following these
events many would pull Cindy
aside are you ready to talk about what
happened at Cony Island there's nothing
to talk about Manny I did what I had to
do to get the job done your agent is
back safe and sound mission accomplished
you used mortars and almost got everyone
killed I took the enemy toys away from
them and we found out about keener's
involvement that's a win that's a war
crime you're going to take me to the ha
I'm worried about you Cindy I'm fine we
have work to do if we're going after
kener you're going to need a good drone
operator Kelo is going after kener
you're staying here until I know what
the hell to do with
you you're not my supervisor you don't
get to make that call you're right no
one is really in charge but you're my
friend and I'm worried about you I want
you to talk to Dr Billings you think I'm
crazy I think you've had to disconnect
from the daily horror we see to survive
it and starting to change you in ways
that make me concerned and if this
doctor clears me can I go to New York if
Mitch says you're good to go I won't
stop you
deal Cindy would head off to see Dr
Mitchell Billings and attempt to gain
approval to join Kelo in New York
City how you doing Cindy oh just great
you know all sunshine and red rainbows
it's like life is so beautiful it's
perpetual summer you don't have to worry
about your unemployed drone operator how
do you think I'm doing disappointed and
tired so you talked to Dr Billings I
thought those meetings were confidential
he didn't tell me anything he wasn't
supposed to I know you I know your tired
face I know you must be disappointed and
you're still here so he clearly did not
give you permission to go to New York
with Kelso so what are you a detective
now too what were you bored and needed
another job how can I help you can't
help I'm broken and everything I
normally do to forget I'm broken I'm not
allowed to do anymore so here we are you
need a hobby no I don't you need to
spend some time with real people get out
from behind the screen go touch some
grass or help Mel with a farm the only
farming I've done is crypto that's great
you've already got Farm experience no
Manny that's not what it means it never
mind I guess I could give it a
try Cindy I need your help with
something good to see you too how was
your summer mine was great thanks sorry
you're right how are you you know the
usual trying to stay positive in the
face of impending disaster we're trying
to grow tomatoes in the fall this seems
like it might be a mistake your what
Manny you want to update
Kelso I need to get back to the castle
what the hell is going on what's wrong
with Cindy nothing is wrong she just
needed to take a break but we need her
she's our Eye in the Sky if Paul's
reports are correct you've gotten pretty
good at being the eye in the sky I'm not
as good as Cindy and I can't be in the
field if I'm doing recon that's true a
very good reason to keep Cindy on Farm
Duty Farm Duty I thought that was a joke
wait until you try the tilapia and
tomato salad I promise you mari's
cooking is no
joke Mari who the [__] is
Mari so Cindy has now been reassigned to
the castle siment many thinks that some
time away from computer monitors will do
us some good unfortunately poor Kelo
who's been away in New York she has
missed a lot of what's been going on in
DC Cindy I'd like you to meet your
newest recruit Wall-E nice to meet you
Wall-E any special skills I should know
about for job placement are you serious
yes okay um engineer computers helped
run a nuclear power plant for the last 6
months so infrastructure and power how
are you at puzzles great love them the
more impossible to solve the better I
recovered this encrypted file from a
hunter drone haven't been able to break
the encryption maybe you could take a
stab at it oh sure is that my job now if
you can crack the encryption sweet I was
a little worried you were going to put
me to work shucking corn or some
[__] you're an engineer if you're
going into food production I'd put you
on the aquaponic system you got a fish
farm we
do you should be
resting this is my job go do your
job go get our people back Manny if
you're not going to do that you're not
the man I thought you were I love
you I love you too go do your job before
it's too
late Manny Manny come in this is sent
Johnson I'm better lead on the recruiter
this is Manny good to hear from you
agent Johnson it's been a while honestly
I thought you were dead I get that a lot
I was following up on a lead about the
Arnolds and got word the recruiter was
moving Vic to a secure location that's
great at least we know they're still
alive the rumors are true Sova is
putting them to work she's not
interested in assassinating them so much
as what they can do for her I'm not sure
which is worse she thinks she can turn
our people to her side or that it might
be
working agent get ready we have a
lead agent Johnson has found a lead on
Cindy's whereabouts he has tracked her
to the East Mall
District the first location Johnson seen
the agents to is the Metro ruins there
are reports Cindy has been spotted
nearby agents roll up to the control
point and are immediately greeted by
hordes of Black Tusk soldiers
fortunately some much needed help would
come along as the jtf would assist in
gaining control of the
compound the agents would eventually
clear out the Hostile presence including
the elimination of Two Black Tusk
leaders and this is when agent Johnson
provide an update on Cindy's
position system
Rea Black Tusk are moving down
Independence Avenue
Southwest well
done agents track the Black Tusk
movement down to a large building
complex in the northeastern side of the
district after killing a handful of
guards on the street they make their way
into the building fighting through they
come across one of the first black dusk
leaders on site but they wouldn't find
this much of a challenge as they steamed
forward after killing what seemed like
an infinite wave of hostiles the final
Target would eventually make themselves
known but because the agents spent far
too much time fluffing around or getting
lost the enemy Target would eventually
end up leaving their fortified position
and coming to them but this wouldn't
help them much they took no time dealing
with them and once eliminated Johnson
would once again be heard of of the
coms taking
fire hostile radio
intercepted we need someone with
programming experience at the solar farm
I'm just a drone operator Cindy you're
not just a drone operator you're so much
more than that at least you could be I
see your potential please don't diminish
your
talent agent get to the solar farm Sova
is trying to manipulate Cindy lattery
won't work with her she's smarter than
[Music]
that agents quickly made their way over
to the solar farm in hopes that they
would be able to intercept the Black
Tusk before they once again move on with
Cindy in a calculated and coordinated
assault the agent stormed the control
Point engaging in a firefight against
the entrenched black Tusk forces but
with jtf backup the agents were able to
push through the W of Black Tusk that
continued to trickle out of the
facility after removing the leader and
then defending the site from a heavy
push back by the Black Tusk attempting
to reclaim the site the agents once
again hear from
Johnson bomb is almost
down agent Cindy spotting at the Museum
of native peoples hopefully the water's
still on I used to love that
place making the way over to the museum
just slightly south of their position
the agents track a unit of Black Tusk
who are suspected of holding Cindy after
clearing the guards out front they are
send several floors into the building
where they are met by another huge group
of hostile soldiers making the way to
the roof they contined to take down
members of this Black Tusk unit until
eventually the leader would make himself
known
upon elimination Johnson would update
the agents on the knck
[Music]
location ass agent we located Cindy
mallister she's at the air in Space
Museum I don't know we still a wants
with her but Cindy is one of us she
can't be turned
it was clear that the agents had caught
up with them as there were vast numbers
of elite Black Tusk that were spewing
out from an entranceway located under
the compound it's at this point that I
must apologize to a Mr stick for not
being able to assist based on your
username I'd say they likely wouldn't be
a lot in the way of conversations we
could have that would be appropriate for
YouTube the agents continued to push
through the facility climbing up into
different levels clearing wave after
wave in some areas the agents felt that
their more defensive style of build
choice was just feeling a little bit
slow with other areas feeling like they
were just running around in the
circles to need a bucket wait what did
he
say to need a bucket yeah I'm just going
to assume that I'm hearing that wrong
continuing to push through the onslaught
of Black Tusk that were being thrown at
them they would eventually come across
several of the leaders that have
bunkered down throughout the facility
once the final leader had been dropped
jtf would move in and rescue Cindy
taking her back to the
castle thanks for the rescue agent it's
super weird to be on this side of the
mission glad you're safe Cindy agent
meet us back at the
castle thanks for the rescue agent I
know you must think of me as silly Cindy
the Drone operator and sometimes trigger
happy mortar operator but I promise I
like my new job better it's a better fit
so if you need someone to recruit I'm
your
recruiter C's new job is finding roles
for people new to the castle settlement
so yes as she was trolling us there she
technically is the recruiter in the
recruitment section of the castle
settlement but not the actual Hunter
recruiter we're looking for or is she no
I I really don't think she
[Music]
is Cindy it's good to have you back
please don't hug me you look like you're
going to hug me are you okay I've been
better I've been
worse I'm ready to get back to work and
pretend this [__] never happened doc
Billings won't be happy but I'm good
thank you while I could use your help
we've been having issues with the mobile
shade server what kind of issues I I
have no idea the computer thing was
never really my area I'll talk to w-e it
really is good to see you you too
Manny so Cindy was our Dr operator she
would make some questionable calls and
it was discovered that she wasn't coping
with everything going on and needed to
step down and take on some different
responsibilities Cindy would then be
captured as part of the Black Tusk
attack and Natalia would try to swear to
work on other systems however the agents
were able to track her down with the
help of agent Johnson and bring her
home nothing huge to pull apart here
like I mentioned in the other video I
really don't trust agent Johnson and how
he has suddenly turned up but I suspect
we'll hear more about him later
something that was mentioned at the
start of this rescue and then once again
at the end was the problems they seem to
be having with a mobile shd
server hey agent it's Wall-E agent
Johnson found a lead on Cindy good thing
the network is stable the mobile shade
server has been a little touchy the
mobile shd server is the reason we were
quickly able to bounce back after the
attack on the White House Natalia had
also attacked one of the shd cores and
then taken down the division Network
this means that none of the agent
technology would work no skills no HUD
no communication and no ISAC however we
had the mobile shd
server it's unclear how many of them we
have but the network has gone down a
couple of times now because of attacks
and without the mobile server the agents
would have been severely HED so while
this seems like something minor right
now I believe the mobile server issues
could lead to something larger much
later
on before before the outbreak of the
green poison Mel established himself as
a skilled writer releasing non-fiction
literature centered around the green and
sustainable living additionally he
delved into crafting fictional
narratives that embodied those
eco-friendly principles certain
enthusiasts perceived Mel's writings as
a guiding Beacon offering insights into
constructing a more promising tomorrow a
certain fan Cassandra Reigns exhibited
an unstable Obsession passionately
urging Mel to align with their
cause those who don't recognize this
name Cassandra Reigns was featured in
the division compromise novel where
Reigns would lead a group of
environmental extremists who were dead
set on helping the world repair their
first targets were Texan oil refineries
they want to see the world free from
fossil
fuels however it was these fuels that
were also the lifeline to helping the
truckies Supply various settlements of
survivors with food and
supplies um Manny have you seen anyone
to check on Proteus Proteus at the jtf s
Squad you sent to Kenley College last
week we haven't heard from them in 3
days that's not right I didn't send
anyone to Kenley College well someone
did they took a mobile shade server with
them and they should be in contact with
your agents you really haven't heard
anything I'm sorry no I haven't heard
anything about Kenley College what's the
name of the squad leader Jack Arnold and
what's your name Mel Arnold Jack your
brother my wife okay thanks Mel I'll see
what I can
do where's Jack I'm sorry we haven't
heard anything back from the team well
then send another team to get him we
don't have those kind of resources then
find them I wish I could either you
value your people or you don't you don't
just send people on a mission and then
leave them to die especially not someone
like Jack we're doing the best we can
you mean the division I'm sorry but we
can't just send agents on a wild goose
chase to the middle of nowhere you've
got a helicopter you've got a location
you've got a Target Proteus you're
missing jtf Squad that is not a wild
goose chase Manny agents choose their
missions ultimately it's not up to me
I'm just a coordinator but you decide if
they know she's missing you decide what
missions agents know about don't pretend
there isn't power and responsibility in
that Jack is jtf you used to be jtf
you're not division Manny you have the
power to bring our girl home if you
decide to give a [__] about the people
and not the
mission as a quick refresher task force
Proteus was a jtf squad that was a
established to scaven any supplies they
could find in DC after several weeks the
Convoy came across Kenley College Jack
decided to investigate the campus to see
what they could find but would end up
getting ambushed by the
outcasts the outcasts killed 99% of the
jtf in the Convoy and looted the
supplies including military grade
servers encrypted radio handsets
chemicals explosives a jtf engineer and
a mobile shd
server you wanted to see me thank you
for coming Mill what do you want Manny
to apologize you're right I forgot where
I came from I got too focused on the big
picture I started to forget about the
people I'm responsible for thank
you any update on Jack
yes
Mel are you serious Manny send his
agents to get me are you hurt I'll be
fine what the hell happened Outcast
followed us to the College I thought I
lost you me too let's get you cleaned up
thank you
Manny as Manny rebuilds the castle
siment he recruits the United Mel and
Jack to run food production and
storage you look happy what's wrong
nothing's wrong just had a meeting with
Manny about reclaiming the castle we're
going to set up some long-term food
security there a farm and storage
seriously yeah you're not worried you're
going to get bored frankly I invite
boring you want you want us to find a
job on the farm for you could be fun
getting your hands dirty I'm good kind
of trying to keep my hands clean and not
take on too much sounds like someone has
been talking to Billings I can neither
confirm nor deny that his sessions are
helping I kind of hate that they're
helping it's okay to admit that you need
help and it's super okay to admit that
therapy help it's not therapy just
counseling whatever helps you sleep that
night
sweetie if you need a new laptop we
recovered a case of them from odia vix
Leed panned out I still can't believe
we're working with that guy I thought he
was such an [__] oh he's he's still
an [__] but now he's a helpful
[__] he's our [__] can y'all stop
calling me an [__] you know I can
hear you
right
agents receive Intelligence on Mel's
possible location at the texi graveyard
in the Foggy Bottom District of
Washington DC they mobilize quickly and
find The Outpost heavily defended by
true Sun
soldiers once the hostiles were cleared
and the compound secured it quickly
became evident that Mel was no longer on
site it was at that moment that agent
Johnson suddenly announced the increase
of Black Tusk activity at the greenhouse
the agents redirect their focus and set
off towards the the southern side of the
[Music]
district proceeding through the front
door the building looks abandoned
however once they had made it through to
the Courtyard several true Suns could be
seen dotted around the agents quickly
maneuver through the courtyard and
engage the true Suns it was clear that
there were more than just a few hostiles
on site but fortunately the agents had
brought along their new toy the
orus
out they never really stood a
chance after climbing another flight of
stairs they eventually come face to face
with a black task high value Target once
eliminated a hostile comms was
[Music]
intercepted hostile radio
intercepted you feeling okay M uh yeah
yeah I just need to rest uh we should be
safe at Navy
Hill you heard him agent get to Navy
Hill you
got
agents swiftly Converge on the compound
the true suns have fortified the area
but the agents undeterred navigate the
barricades and overcome wave after wave
of hostile
forces their perseverance pays off as
they successfully neutralize two
prominent leaders within the true Sun's
ranks hostile radio
intercepted hello is anyone there
they're keeping me at Columbia Plaza
agent if you can hear this please get me
the hell out out of
[Music]
here agents confront Fierce resistance
from the true Suns upon arriving at the
entrance of the Columbia Plaza
broadcast with determination they
navigate the structure eliminating all
hostiles they
encounter eventually they would face off
against a true Sun leader once
eliminated Johnson's voice would once
again be heard over the air
pieces we tracked Mel Arnold to
Roosevelt Island I have no idea why
sooba would take them
there diving straight in there the
agents waste no time charging onto
roosev Island Mel is a civy they never
should have been put in this
position as they delve deeper into the
facility waves of enemies grow in size
and intensity you're
mine pushing through the compound
eliminating Kel hostiles another enemy
communication would be intercepted
passing
grenade hostile radio
intercepted do you need anything
fertilizer maybe the crops look
hungry
CRS the agents continue their Relentless
Advance battling through room after room
facing a horde of true Sun soldiers but
the agents are undeterred making precise
shots and effortlessly dispatching
enemies left and right
as they push deeper into the island they
finally come face to face with the
formidable true Sun leader who joins the
fight except when I say face to face I
actually mean he was miles away and when
I say formidable I actually didn't even
know it was a leader he just died really
fast but you get the
point area
secure what the hell's going on that's
what I'd like to know agent meet us back
at the
castle
[Music]
oh I can't believe you took the time to
find me I'm impressed Manny would make
the effort I'm just a farmer now I guess
he hasn't forgotten the jtf and the
division are supposed to work for the
people after
all now have you seen Agent Johnson no
why I wanted to talk to him about the
recruiter wor are the issues with a
mobile shade server connected somehow
I'm fine no lingering Trauma from being
kidnapped by the Black Tusk thank you
for asking sorry how are you good you
know apparently still your conscience
and I need to remind you to stop
focusing on the conspiracy that isn't
there and instead focus on the people in
front of you that you have volunteered
to keep safe yeah you're right you're
right
I just I can't believe I lost them you
got them back I saw Mari she looks great
seemed pissed at you but she looked
great yeah I'm working on fixing things
there too maybe you should stop trying
to fix things and just do your job go
get our people back so you talked to
maray I did but I want to talk to Jack
do your job and get my wife back
again like all of the others Manny
catches up with Mel after he is safely
brought home to the castle somewhat
annoyingly Manny is once again being
told by Mel that he needs to focus on
the people in front of him not the large
Mission at play I understand if his job
is just to look after the settlements
especially the castle settlement this
should be his main concern but he is
currently still a coordinator for the
division the bigger pitcher around the
recruiter soov the Black Tusk and Calvin
McManus absolutely should be at the
Forefront of his mind with with muray
and his future family maybe it's time
for many to step down as the coordinator
and for someone who isn't quite so close
and emotionally invested in the people
within the settlement to take over and
keep the division moving towards the
bigger
[Music]
goals Jack Arnold is a jtf specialist
and was the squad leader for Proteus
task force Proteus was established to
scour the streets of DC and scavenge any
supplies they could find
after several weeks the Convoy came
across Kinley College Unfortunately they
weren't the first ones to visit the
campus the outcast had set up camp there
and it wasn't long before task force
Proteus found themselves in the middle
of an ambush the outcasts killed 99% of
the jtf in the Convoy and looted the
supplies including military grade
servers encrypted radio handsets
chemicals explosives a jtf prisoner and
a mobile shd server Jack would be one of
the lucky few who survived but as a
hostage she'll be forced to build
improvised explosive devices for the
outcasts agents would eventually go on
to rescue Jack from Kinley college and
reunite them with their partner Mel
since returning to DC jack has been
monitoring Intel collected by the mobile
HD server whilst also managing the
Castle's food
storage I don't know why they followed
us Mel City took a mobile shade server
yeah so we can stay in contact with your
agents it's how I send the distress call
but I think we out of range the network
went down we had to get it back up and
running before we got the call [__] what
did I miss too much I can let Mel fill
you in later what happened to the agent
who sent us to Kenley agent yeah he was
supposed to meet us there but he never
showed he told us to bring the server do
you remember his name uh John Tom
Richardson honestly I don't remember it
was a pretty generic white boy name no
worries we can check the logs are we
done here yeah can I go see M now I
asked them to meet us here thank you
anything else I should know about other
than the network going down oh not much
agents recover president Ellis the
hyenas had him he tried to Stage a
military coup he's with the Black Tusk
it's
complicated in a post-rescue briefing
with Manny Jack explains that they had
an shd server on them so they could keep
in contact the division of course this
was at a time when the full shd Network
had been taken down so no one back at
the base of operations received their
distress call Jack had obviously been
held captive for quite some time as she
was oblivious to all of the major events
that have been playing out one
interesting thing she mentions here is
that it was an agent who sent task force
Proteus to Kenley and if we remember
from M's rescue many had no idea why and
who sent them there so this agent while
still in DC was working completely
separately to the team our agents have
been working with up until now on top of
this it was him who told her to bring
the server yet he never showed up when
the outcasts sprung their trap Jack
wasn't able to name the agent but I
would place a fairly solid bit on it
being someone who we've only recently
started interacting with but why he
would do this I don't know I have my
suspicions but I'll talk about that a
little bit later
on hey Manny thanks for meeting with me
you wanted to show me something yeah
when we turn the mobile shade server
back on we recovered some files they
seemed important and maybe something you
wouldn't want everyone know about what
kind of files recordings mostly
conversations between a defense
contractor and someone named Cal do you
have them with you I copied part of one
over before we had to charge the server
when we turned it back on the original
recordings were gone and there was new
Intel someone talking about a play it
was weird the server must have been
damaged back at Kenley can we hear the
one you have sure it's not much but this
is what we managed to record before the
battery died well I know our pockets as
deep as yours hopefully you play nice in
the bidding war today oh Cal I don't
want to start a war with you sorry I
know it's not much but it seemed
important if it was on the server thanks
Jack honestly I don't know what to do
with that but if you get any more files
try and record them before you reboot
the server we'll
do Jack provides many an update on the
mobile shd server she's having trouble
collecting information and suspects it
may have been damaged at Kinley as it
only has partial messages and some are
being lost after rebooting for anyone
not aware that one part that was played
was actually the very first descent coms
that drops it's Kelvin mcmanis and
Natalia Sova meeting with Ortiz robotics
to discuss the new AI they've been
working on
Isaac the other one she mentioned about
a play is actually another one we hear
later on that is part of a number of
discussions between Kelvin and an NSA
analyst who discovered early signs of
concern regarding Gordon Amherst
another recording yeah we've got a name
on the mystery woman great let's hear it
Natalia
sakova as I live and breathe Cal is it
wrong that I expected you to die in the
first wave not at all Nat most of my
colleagues and those bureaucrats did
you'd think being at Ground Zero would
have been a death sentence turns out I
had the infrastructure in place to
weather the storm well I'm glad to see
you're thriving given the conditions
you're not doing too bad yourself n I'm
not how's our boy officially installed
as president since Mendes was taken care
of good good and now presumed dead since
Air Force One crashed and we never
recovered his body presumed dead or
confirmed dead presumed I've got him
squirreled away until he's ready to play
ball he forgot his place in this
organization and started to make some
decisions on his own can't have the
puppets doing the puppeteering exactly
Jack manages to extract another
recording this one is from after the
outbreak and the first wave have been
activated and subsequently fell Kelvin
actually confirms that most of his
colleagues and the political structure
in the White House have fallen to the
green poison and that he is one of the
last ones left this actually ansers a
few questions around where he is
currently sitting in the presidential
line of succession in present day this
comms also confirms that he is well
aware and involved in the black task
having taken care of the former
president and order to place Ellis in
his place it would appear that this is
around the time where Ellis was having
second thoughts better his Allegiance
with Natalia which actually wasn't too
long before fa Lao had him
killed Calvin and Natalia have been
working on this for a long time she was
surprised he wasn't Dead from the
outbreak but they certainly seem to have
been planning this for a
while agents receed Intel that jaet
could be being held at the Washington
Monument in the w pomac Park District of
DC calling in for jtf support they storm
the control point there they find the
Monument riddled with true sun and Black
Tusk
soldiers once cleared the hostiles would
attempt a Counterattack but this would
prove fruitless as the agents hunkered
down and picked them off at
range although Jack was nowhere to be
seen on site a hostile coms that was
intercepted would tell the agents that
Jack has recently been at the medical
camp
keep hostile radio
intercepted Vic where are they taking us
the medical Camp what why who knows
maybe to make sure we're not infected
maybe to feed us to the Troops they look
hungry Vick is not
funny rogue agent detected
after dispatching a surprised group of
Rogues who were taking advantage of the
distraction agents would quickly move
Northwest of their
[Music]
position tracking down Target Vladimir
monk Davis the agents hope to intercept
the Black Tusk movements before they
once again are able to move Jack to
another location fighting through his
henchmen and sniper doggos they would
eventually meet up with him in the
center of a long since abandoned Sarah
Camp while his bodyguards proved to be a
little tougher than they had anticipated
the agents fought through and would pick
up another hostile
Communications hostile
radio where's Vick don't worry about him
he's someone else's problem now I'm not
going to lie the Mast is a hell of a lot
more peaceful without him here sorry
Vic confirmed I've got eyes on Jack at
the
mast
while they were once gain too late the
mass control Point wasn't far away so
they wasted no time moving
on the agents once again called in for
support from the jtf unfortunately this
time they seem to be a little bit
distracted by something that was
obviously more important on the streets
outside of the compound so the agents
were on their
own finding a favorable position
overlooking the entrances they were able
to lock down the area and pick off any
incoming
hostiles once eliminated agent Johnson
could be heard over the air
[Music]
pieces agent we track ja to the site of
Crash drone we'll get you the
[Applause]
[Music]
coordinates after Johnson sent through
the coordinates the agents wasted no
time in moving and forcing their hand of
which they really brought something to
the table that they certainly weren't
expecting a
crap
moving through the drone crash site they
would meet heavy Black Tusk resistance
which would have the agents questioning
the gear they chose to use in this hunt
but regardless they pushed through it
wouldn't be long before the main hostile
Target in the area would be spotted and
after effortlessly disposing of the
Black Tusk soldiers they would take him
down once again being alerted by agent
Johnson to a new location that Jack was
last
spotted I need to swap this armor
out agent we've located Jack Arnold at
Capital
Hill Jack Arnold's last known location
was at the Hostile stronghold of Capital
Hill rushing on and there the agents
find themselves surrounded on multiple
sides perhaps the less than stealthy
apparel that used to wear was working
against
them Jack's still pretty messed up after
what happened at Kenley college but
she's found
the outcast abducted
her leading up towards the capital
building they were met with huge
resistance including headshot stack
destroying warhounds but they pushed
through with Superior drone surveillance
and accuracy deep into the building they
found themselves completely encircled by
Black Tusk forces but while ducking in
and out of cover taking pinpoint shots
on their opponents which actually means
very little because they were using the
extremely overpowered determined Talent
they were able to force the Hostile
command out of their entrenchment
the Black Tusk leader spent more time
announcing their presence in the fight
than firing her weapon and the Agents
would in turn be awarded by another
exotic component to be added to the
resource pole after clearing out the
rest of the opposition the agents would
learn that Brian Johnson and the jtf
have managed to extract Jack and take
her back to the
castle area
secure I'll get Jack back to the castle
nice work
[Music]
agent what's wrong with the server you
should really go find Mel they're
worried sick about you I will as soon as
you tell me what the hell is going on
with the server it's having trouble
connecting to the network range is
spotty like something is interfering
with it maybe overloading it since when
since the attack no since we got muray
back who's working on it Cindy and Wally
Brian said he'd take a look but I
honestly don't know how much help he can
be we fixed it the server was stable
there was nothing wrong with it are you
sure it started acting up after Mari
came back it was fine that night and
then in the morning it started acting
up anything else strange happened
nothing really agent Johnson came back
but he's been trying to help us fix it
maybe he was damaged in the attack we
just didn't
notice after Jack's second rescue Manny
catches up with her for a debrief sadly
for her husband Mel she is more
concerned about the mobile shd server
and what's happening with it but this is
obviously because she's more than aware
of the potentially valuable Intel it
holds that she's already almost lost her
life to while it looks like there are
connection issues it was pointed out and
then confirmed that this only started
happening after Mari Singh was rescued
and brought back home in her absence
Cindy Wally and even agent Johnson have
been working on
AIX Jack proclaims that it was working
fine before the attack and then her
capture so why would it start acting up
now after Mari got back and this is a
fair question but I don't think Mari has
anything to do with it as it was also
during this time that agent Johnson
suddenly appeared do I think this is
related yes I absolutely do but let's
get back to this in a
second it's been a while yeah sorry
about that been busy setting up the farm
and the food storage we haven't done a
sync on the server in a while what did
you
find n I'd like you to meet the
recruiter the recruiter from my hunter's
replacement he's going to be responsible
for Bonnie's test make sure he's as good
as you say he is and ready to join our
little
organization right nice to meet you Mr
recruiter Hunters have been instructed
not to speak you never know who's
listening and what kind of voice
recognition software they have running
you're paranoid Cal rather be paranoid
than wrong well you've made it this far
with a being discovered so maybe there
is something to your methods Cal that's
quite the compliment coming from you Nat
you get this man to a fair day cage and
you can get to know him better until
then please inform your Black Tusk to
only address my agent as the
recruiter this piece of Intel is much
closer to present day where Jack is long
since been recovered from Kinley college
and has fully taken on a new role in the
castle sediment the coms talk about
Natalia being introduced to the
recruiter before our first viewing of
him where Bonnie was being tested to see
whether he was suitable for the hunter
program there isn't anything huge to
dissect here but it does answer a few of
the much wider theories I've seen
floating around about the hunters we're
now learning why the hunters don't talk
it's not that they can't it's that they
shouldn't so there is a lot to process
here when I was told by The Narrative
director that I would enjoy what this
rescue would bring to our attention she
absolutely wasn't wrong at this stage at
least through what I'm seeing it would
be fair to have all fingers point at
agent Johnson right now while I do
believe he is playing a part in
sabotaging the mobile shd server I'm not
completely convinced that he's the
recruiter I can't even give any solid
reason for this it's just that something
doesn't quite add up for me here I just
see him as a soldier who's extremely
loyal to Kelvin Kelvin has imp planted
within to help with removing any proof
that he can get his hands on that shows
certain interactions that may paint
Kelvin and in a less than favorable
light he mentioned that most of his
colleagues have been taken out by the
green poison and now that Ellis is dead
he could be the next in
line being Rogue doesn't mean what it
used to and it's looking more now that
instead we have two groups of Agents
fighting for two different
sides technically we could be the Rogues
because we aren't reporting to any sort
of authority where Brian Johnson is
potentially reporting to the
president but how does it change
everything if we know that the president
got there through let's say far less
than ethical
means it's definitely a save or remains
and desperate times call for desperate
measures type
situation however I feel there could be
a slight turn in our favor coming up in
a couple of weeks time we'll be
unmasking the recruiter given the help
that he provided Mari during her rescue
will he be our weit
in before the green poison outbreak V
melik better known as Vic or Vic the
dick was the CEO of odia electronics
once an ally turned Black Tusk puppet
and then once again an ally he isn't
exactly someone who can be trusted But
like everyone else he brings his own
expertise and experience that elevates
the people around him especially in
relation to energy infrastructure Vic
always thinks he's the smartest person
in the room even though this is really
true however he does have some very
strong Connections in the military
industrial complex including Ortiz
robotics Kelvin McManus and Natalia
calov stop keep your hands where I can
see them don't shoot I'm unarmed State
your business I need assistance and
lodging I haven't eaten in days look
I've never seen you before I can't just
let you in can anyone vet you Manny Orga
wait there this is Manny hey Manny sorry
to bother you got a stranger here says
you can vet him what's his name what's
your name tham Malik fiam Malik take him
in a custody I'll be there as soon as I
can keep your hands where I can see them
oh good guess I left an impression I'm
unarmed I'm not a threat we'll see about
that this was sometime after vicam had
betrayed us the first time and left us
to be ambushed by the hyenas it would
appear that he hadn't quite managed to
get what he needed in order to survive
in this new world and would come
crawling back to Society of course vicam
isn't really a name you can forget so
many ordered his immediate arrest
what happened Vic uh you know same old
story fell in with a back crowd friends
used peer pressure you make some bad
choices and end up regretting that
decision and hope it's not too late to
change you led my agents into a trap uh
technically I didn't know it was a trap
until I had to spring it I can't trust
you Malik I'm not asking you to trust me
I'm asking you to align with me against
the mutual enemy Natalia Sova her too if
you're talking about schaer this
conversation is over I'm talking about
cow what do you know about mcmanis how
do you think I met Natalia you know how
they say there are six degrees of
separation to anyone in the world sure
well for Rich [__] in
DC there is three and if you have
defense contracts it's one Calvin
mcmanis you give me Intel on mcmanis and
Sova and we protect you from the hunters
and Black Tusk
that's your offer you also get my
charming personality Superior intellect
and access to odia Tech I'm sure you
could use some Power Solutions as we
move into winter let's see what Intel
you have before you start making
promises you can't keep hey you got the
batteries I never lied to you about the
batteries I just didn't tell you about
the system
wipe while being interrogated by many
vic would go on to tell him about the
fact that he'd been working with a bad
crowd and almost immediately regretted
it so once he was able he escaped and
made his way towards a jtf controlled
settlement it would turn out that he
hadd been working for Natalia since all
the way back then but also Kelvin
mcmanis given the obviously valuable
Intel he has Manny makes him a deal in
return for his
safety system Purge complete I did what
you asked I purged all records of your
involvement with odia do we have a deal
or not just two more things and then I
know I can trust you Vic fine trigger
the alarms and read your lines Nat I I
can't read that I'll sound like an
[__] if you want my help you'll find
a way God damn
it fine oh and do your best to sound
sincere I'll try I know that's hard for
you oops I seem to have tripped the
alarm every hyena inside two blocks is
probably on their way here to
investigate this is actually back when
Vic was in the process of screwing us
over quite some time ago now the whole
reason he was wiing the systems was to
hide Natalia's involvement with Oda like
always Natalia was pulling the strings
and ordering him to do everything on the
fly it was her who forced him to trigger
the alarm and even forced him to say
what he said I wouldn't go as far as to
say that he isn't an [__] he's maybe
just not quite as big an [__] as we
thought he was kind
of
Cal great to see you again Vic what have
you got for me today solar powered relay
stations for all your offsite tactical
power needs this your idea or birdy's
bird's brain my money so you get all the
credit love it you want to place an
order you've got competition on my
production line if you want to get this
out to your troops to test next spring
I'll let Natalia take the A&D hit she
can afford it what I really need are
autonomous power sources that can either
be self- sustaining using solar wind
Hydro or geothermal whichever is more
appropriate for the region that needs
little to no maintenance and is
basically idiot proof and if it can
power climate control an automated
defense system and a CNC machine at the
same time even
better that's too specific to be a
random request Cal oh it's not random
but it's classified
so do you have something that can work
or do we need to take birdie into this
conversation I could hack something
together but what you're talking about
needs to be sight specific and that's
going to require bird's brain for a
modular site specific generator or
custom builds for each classified
location so if you want to keep it
modular we need
birdie this is the first time we hear of
Birdie Vic's sister she is someone it
sounds like we really need on our side
someone like CLA Ortiz an absolute
technical genius so where is she
now agents receive Intel that Vic could
be being held at the new Venice control
point in the West End District of DC the
control point is completely full of the
Suns out guns out true Sun soldiers but
before signaling for jtf support the
agents greet The Defenders using the
festive weapon of choice the O Carol
countering the jtf attack the true suns
were never able to regain control of the
complex and will find themselves
succumbing to The Marksman fire in a Hil
of confetti and
fireworks upon eliminating The Last
Enemy agent Johnson alerted the agents
to a confirmed sighting of Vic in the
historic
district got him you're going confirm
sighting of Vic in the historic district
we could have done that without you made
it
[Music]
through agents were able to track down a
high value Target known as Alona chipm
Mark Dakota the Black Tusk officer had
locked down this neighborhood with a
large contingent of true Suns fighting
through between and on top of the
buildings they would eventually meet up
with chipmunk rather than going down and
meeting them on the street the agents
decided to keep spreading the Christmas
cheer from
above the target
agent once eliminated a hostile conss
was
[Music]
intercepted hostile radio
intercepted why did you bring me here
Nat you said you needed more fuel for
your batteries I do but no one has
delivered gas to the Riverside Station
in almost a year
whatever is here is
worthless it would be discovered that
Vic was last seen at the Riverside
Station the agents pack up their gear
and quickly make their way to the
site the agents once again called in for
support from the jtf taken by surprise
the true Suns on site rushed out onto
the street firing wildly in the
direction of the agents after taking out
the leader they were able to secure a
defensive position above the building
from there they were able to to
comfortably repel the Hostile
Counterattack once the facility was
secured agent Johnson could once again
be heard over the comms they're not in
cover hostile
broadcasted got reports of Vic at the
garage we should check it out or not I
mean does anyone really give a [__]
about
Vic itting down to the Southeastern side
of the district the agents would follow
another lead wasting no time they am
Ambush the defending soldiers on the
street entering below through the
underground car park they were greeted
by another small group of true Sons but
it didn't take long to remove them in
fact their mates in the Next Room didn't
even hear all the fighting and were also
caught by surprise after clearing a few
waves of support the enemy leader would
enter the fight his entire bodyguard
unit would be nice enough to line up and
quickly drop to the agent for mus spam
facing the agents one-onone the high
value Target proved that he had
obviously come into his position purely
because of lack of options from his
superiors as his offense could really
only be described as sad and a little
bit
[Music]
pathetic
agent Scout spotted Vic with the
recruiter at the bank so we're good then
recruiter has Vic and we get to take a
well-deserved nap I mean do we really
need
Vic Target down good
job vicr mik's last known location was
at the bank
headquarters rumor is Vic has a safety
deposit box at the bank and so Cova
wants whatever's inside it I can't
believe were risking your life for vicam
Malik the true Suns had a huge force on
site agents would have to hunker down
and slowly pick them off one by
one once cleared they would move on on
to the next section and greet them with
a series of festive bursts but this was
just a distraction and the Agents soon
found themselves being
flanked that
hurt but this was brought under control
and they were quickly eliminate the
Defenders including a black task officer
and continue moving through the facility
towards the final
Target right
now climbing to the upper levels agents
would be surprised to find hostiles that
were oblivious to the attack playing out
eventually they would find themselves in
a room that they had once rescued a
former president Ellis from the true
Sons had chosen this to be the place of
their Last Stand I'm going to waste
every last one of you
just lie
down got big agent meet me at the castle
then go get my sister
birdie so I heard a rumor Gat did
medical experiments on your pregnant
girlfriend installed a mobile shade
server killer in her uterus and now
everything is [__] I don't have time
for your [__] Vic it's not [__]
Nat took us all for a reason she's
recruiting she's looking to expand her
Empire and what greater get than the
pregnant girlfriend of the last
honorable man in DC Mr accidental pus
himself Manny Orga that's not funny Vic
come on Manny you got to lighten up your
therapist will be very disappointed with
you when was your last session I don't
have time for this I need to find birdie
figure out what's actually wrong with
the server and no I do not believe that
Natalia Sova replaced our baby with a
device that can remotely kill a mobile
shade
server the first time the agents were
introduced to the recruiter it was
during a mission at the gon Trade Center
where he was there to observe Jack
Bonnie and assess whether he was
appropriate as a new recruit for the
hunter program Bonnie the Black Tusk as
well as the recruiter would absolutely
destroy Captain Lewis's true Sons but
despite Bonnie's best efforts he would
eventually be killed by agents who
stormed the compound watching everything
play out the recruiter would allow
himself to be seen but would disappear
shortly after in a cloud of blue smoke
the recruiter wouldn't be heard from
again until the rescue of John yezi in
this situation it was just a passing
message through a hostile comms that had
been intercepted where the recruiter
handed Yazi over to a Black Tusk
operative the last known sighting was at
the end of the Mari sang Rescue he
didn't play any part in the conflict but
he could be seen standing above watching
as the agents called in the extraction
for Mari the recruiter is working for
Kelvin mcmanis his job is to find
suitable replacements for the hunter
program so why is he watching the agents
so
closely
following the vicr melik rescue Johnson
informs the agents that Vic's sister
birdie is being held by the recruiter at
Camp White Oak and he urges the agents
to go in with
support agent the recruiter is holding
birdie at Camp White Oak after the
attack on the White House I don't want
you going in there without support
Wall-E we're going to need the server
it's not stable there's been some
interference the range is limited
limited is better than leaving our
agents without their Tech
you're right you're right agent I'll
have Wally give John the server he can
get you a ride to camp white
o agent glad you can make it when you
land leave the server and start a sweep
I'll get the server from Fernanda and
cover you agent Johnson how did you get
to White out so fast what are you
talking about I've been waiting for you
who did you think located birdie oh
right sorry guess I'm just getting a
little paranoid with everything that's
happened recently that's fair agent as
soon as you land head for the
bridge agents push forward into the
compound and were quickly greeted by
automated
[Music]
defenses moving deeper into Camp White
Oak it was clear that the Black Tusk had
taken the threat seriously their troops
were defending large sections of the
facility with seemingly no shortage of
resource to be thrown into the fight
agent something's wrong with the network
I activated the mobile shade server stay
close I don't know how much range this
thing
has system re
activated unable to access system
reestablish
proximity system
offline agent there's some kind of
interference our comms still work but
we're losing access to the shade Tech
what the hell are you doing what's
happening your agent isn't following
orders and is going to get us all killed
what orders my orders agent head to the
bunker system restored this was a
surprising and somewhat outof character
message from agent Johnson but perhaps
it's the stress of the situation so many
in the agents say nothing in response
and continue with with the job at
hand hey can y'all stop shooting I'm
trying to work here we need to get you
to safety oh [__] this is an a
drill tell them to back the [__] off and
stop shooting birdie who are you talking
to Manny what the hell is going on we're
here to rescue you rescue me what the
[__] are you talking about Black Tusk
have
you again no they don't that said we're
working together now your agents brought
me here what birdie who brought you to
Camp White Oak your agent you know the
one that looks like a [__] park
[Music]
ranger
hey Nat how about you let me go with my
brother and we call it even uhhuh yeah I
fixed your power supply issues and
haven't killed anyone yet so how about
you let me go we leave with the server
and call it
even the agents continue to fight
through the hordes of Black Tusk and
would eventually find themselves closing
in on the
lodge agent Johnson come in agent
Johnson the team on site has lost access
to their Tech God damn it Johnson where
are
you enemy is
running so I guess Johnson is an [__]
thanks for the rescue
agent agent clear Camp White Oak for
extraction where's the server Johnson
has it oh that makes sense what does he
want with the server brdy Nat is trying
to build I'll tell you later this
Channel's not secure they've infiltrated
our comms your comms are their comms
keep up
[Music]
Manny hey so Johnson or uh should I call
you Mr recruiter what are you up to
birdie oh nothing just hijacking your
mortars for the opposition Force figured
with all of Cal's toys it wasn't really
a fair bite hey agent get to the helipad
before this [__] gets away with the
server go have it yes N I have the
server but birdie blew my cover facing
heavy opposition time to suit up Mr
recruiter we are so [__] hey Vic how
did you get on this channel I told you
no coms with their coms no one ever
listens Vic get off the comms go get a
taco or something
it was at this moment when the agents
would learn that it was one of their own
who was at the Helm of the program that
was responsible for the elimination of
so many of their colleagues but there
was no time to dwell on this now they
needed to keep pushing forward before
the recruiter agent Johnson was able to
get away with the mobile HD
server the agents find themselves once
again locked down by a seemingly
unlimited number of hostiles defending
the lodge but through patience and
stubbornness to admit that this was the
wrong build to be bring into this fight
they would slowly pull the defense apart
and move towards the final
[Music]
Target mat send the Healer for
extraction copy that agent this is it
hit them with everything you've
got system
curtailed
weak points
detected
agent you know you're on the wrong side
of this war right we serve at the
pleasure of the president we work for
Homeland we work for cow it doesn't
matter if Isaac thinks you're on Mission
the minute you allied with Kelo you went
rogue you think I'm evil because I'm a
Hunter we're the only ones still on
Mission if an agent steps out of line
we're here to clean up the M
can't system back
online system
noing system
restored after a few practice runs
president you can't beat him pleasure of
the president the agents knew exactly
what to do and would rush in to put a
stop to Johnson before he was able to
get away with the mobile shd
server you can't beat him with shade
Tech agent you should listen to birdie I
can help you but I need to take down the
network you can't do that birdie can't
or won't I definitely can I just need to
upload the countermeasure then none of
you will have your little
toys again through complete stubborness
and a willingness to see this through
agents would eventually figure out the
massively overpowered recruiter attack
pattern and alongside Bird's stripping
of the network they would slowly break
down his armor but over and over again
he would come back breaking any obstacle
birdie would put in
place however she had a backup
plan agent you can't beat him with your
Tech I have a workaround give me a
minute birdie what are you doing don't
worry about it Mr recruiter birdie you
know me H I know you're full of [__] and
we'll do anything for the mission damn
it birdie you know what we're up against
I do agent get clear
birdie system
malfunctioning
loser advaning system
restored
a you're making a
mistake clever
girl
oh
[__] Cal will be
disappointed Johnson was a special
project of his too bad he was a true
patriot well I suppose I should
congratulate you you took out Cal's
favorite Hunter and recovered your
precious mobile shade server well done
agent is this all just a game to you of
course not but I know when to cut my
losses regroup learn from my mistakes
and come back stronger can you say the
same Manny this isn't over of course not
oh send my best to Mari she really is
quite the Spitfire I can see why you
fell for her she is going to be an
excellent mother you two finished yet I
want to go home taures you're clear for
extraction what did n want with the
server who the Natalia Sova who's that
[Applause]
she's can you please stop messing with
me nope you're too easy you know if you
would have come for me first I could
have told you what she wanted with the
server what the hell are you talking
about N I know what she wants with the
servers seriously yeah she wants them
for her Tech could the Black Tusk really
modify the server for their Tech with
the right code anything is possible you
just have to find the right code or the
right coder birdie did you give her the
right code [__] no that is not my area
you need a programmer a hacker someone
who speaks those languages you need a
Wall-E or a CLA or Myra and a server she
would need a working
server while we were there to rescue
birdie she wasn't really being held
captive birdie knows what net wants with
the service to be able to use it for the
black tus Tech fortunately coding this
to work for net isn't something that
birdie is able to do because if she
could have she would have it could be
easy to assume that that birdie is an
[__] or not to be trusted like a
brother Vic but there is more to the
story birdie is obviously a driven
individual and as we heard in the Vic
rescue she is the brains of their
operation the thing that drives her is
challenge and this is something that
Natalia was able to
provide birdie you seem Restless maybe a
little bored I am bored anything I can
do to help combat the boredom uh a
challenge maintaining the bunkers isn't
challenging enough for you it's not a
challenge Nat it's a job jobs are boring
no matter how cool they are once you
learn how to do everything it starts to
get a little boring what kind of
challenge are you looking for don't
worry nothing illegal well no more
illegal than you and the cabal boys are
used to how may I challenge you birdie
you remember that Sim CLA was working on
I do it sounded like fun with a couple
of mods it could be a real challenge
what kind of mods huh evolve the area of
effect give the dummies live rounds and
see what happens I'll see what I can do
in the meantime I've got schematics I'd
like your opinion
on how many people is this supposed to
support as many as
possible so I guess the question is why
is she helping Natalia Bird's thirst for
Challenge and the drive for the
opportunity to fix problems in her areas
of personal interest is what motivates
her the biggest stuff happening in the
background it holds no signicance to her
on top of this Natalia knows this and is
manipulating her more gble
side Su bro birdie you okay you look
okay they they didn't hurt you why would
they hurt me because you were there what
the hell birdie Nat held you captive for
6 months Manny sends his civilian Army
to rescue you cuz who the [__] knows
where Kelo is and all you have to say is
sup bro I'm fine your guys got me out of
there Mario made me a fish tacu and this
place seems pretty chill so yeah sup bro
I I love you I love you too I I missed
you bunches what have you been up to oh
you know left to die taken in by my
mortal enemies uh left to die taken in
by not so mortal enemies who also hate
my moral enemies dude so that wasn't
into you you got to let it go man that's
not she kidnapped you and made me into
her battery [__] yeah about that why
didn't you just set up solar relays on
the hovercrafts cuz I didn't really want
to help them all right right I probably
shouldn't have converted their engines
to Electric then um my bad you're really
okay yeah why wouldn't I be Nat had me
on all kinds of top secret projects
never boring you know what they say
aboard birdie is a dangerous birdie
secret projects oh yeah you ever seen an
underground city set up to wait out a
new nuclear winner can't say I have me
neither but the blueprints look
promising on the other side of Natalia's
manipulation of Birdie we've now ended
up with someone who has more information
around what Natalia has been up to than
ever before including plans to create an
underground city built to outlast a
nuclear winter perhaps they were
planning to use the nuclear football way
back when Ellis was alive this was going
to be their way of ensuring only those
in favor with the new overlords would
survive still this seemed to a little
bit over the top so maybe this was just
a backup plan or we're still to hear
more about
this that should do it you're done yeah
we set up solar panels and wind turbines
hooked them up to your relay built a
series of batteries to store the extra
power in case of inclement weather built
a substation to redirect on days with
two good conditions so we don't overload
the system and have three backup
generators just in case one diesel
retrofitted to use the dirty cooking oil
from mari's Taco Shop one Hydro Dr on
rainy days hooked up to the roof's drain
pipes and one people powered that is
just a stationary bike but that's really
only good for making smoothies you want
a smoothie no I'm good margarita oh yes
please you've actually been to their
headquarters oh yeah dozens of times
[__] get breaking needed someone to get
the AC back up and running they really
should have built them all below ground
above the water table the pumps to keep
the water out have a tendency to
overheat the bunkers how do you access
the bunkers biometric lock do you have
clearance me no I wish always had to
have one of those btsu brats accompany
me btsu brats you know one of Nat's
Inner Circle Dolores Jack Galveston bon
bon do you mean Bon Schaefer yeah I
think so been a while since I've seen
him come to think of it past couple
months it's just been Jack
huh how did they get you into the bunker
was it like a hand scanner or something
hand retinal biorhythm and voice
confirmation all four at the same time
not that sophisticated really but hard
to fake if it's not the person
especially the biorhythm a couple of
times Jack got us locked out for an hour
until the system reset cuz he was too
excited about something and his heart
was beating too fast so the person is
the key yeah you could say that but I
don't think anyone would say it like
that
except you Manny you're like the most
dad joke ndad person I've ever met thank
you berie dude that's not a
compliment and this is exactly what I
was talking about manipulation of Birdie
certainly gained Natalia a very helpful
and useful individual but it also
exposed large areas of her organization
to someone who didn't technically work
for her we can see where this is playing
out just this information on its own
shows how valuable B and schaer will be
if he ever wakes up
up I'll admit the recruiter being agent
Johnson was just a little bit of a
disappointment to me to start with
mostly because I had picked him as being
the most likely candidate since the very
first Target this season and it only got
more obvious as the rest of the season
played out perhaps I was hoping for a
bit of a curve ball to be thrown out
there but in saying that for him to be
the most obvious choice means that the
story is playing out in the way that it
was meant to in contrast to some of the
other wacky have come up with in other
story arcs due to perhaps unintended
outcomes of certain
interactions however there has been some
extra Intel that has been included in
this season that actually shows us the
events that led up to Johnson being
recruited into the position of the
recruiter the coms I'm about to play
lead on from the events that played out
in the extremist mice Comics you
certainly don't need to have read these
to understand what's happening here but
if you wanted the full background to the
story I'll have a link to my coverage of
these in the
description sir we're approaching the
coordinates should be in DC by Nightfall
agents done and Ward seem pretty shaken
up by the death of mantis frankly sir I
don't understand what happened back
there I don't know who took the shot or
who would have killed her to keep her
quiet Cindy can I talk to you for a
second sure agent Johnson how can I help
want to talk to you about agent kelo's
Behavior back there right it was awesome
it was Reckless she made a bomb out of
moonshine ha an awesome bomb M made out
of moonshine she could have demolished
the building but she didn't and we got
odessa's daughter back and we took out
St Alex win win and win how well do you
really know agent Kelo as well as anyone
can know a coworker that's what she is
to you a coworker yeah what else would
she be an agent of the division of
course she's an agent but she's also
just a person and people make mistakes
an agent go Rogue all the time so what
people can change that's what worries me
you sure you're cut out for
this I don't know if anyone
is well I guess it's good to see that
Cindy has always been crazy but listen
to what Johnson keeps saying about
Kelo agent Johnson Secretary please call
me Cal could I do for you Cal I heard
about mantis and your little tiff with a
drone operator about agent Kelo I
wouldn't call it a tiff sir I wanted to
commend you for speaking the truth yes
we recruited you and trained you but we
never really prepared for a situation
like this how could we even begin to
predict something like this would ever
happen we were never supposed to be
activated you were a fail safe on a fail
safe on an insurance policy on a
catastrophe that was never supposed to
happen and as this was never supposed to
happen some people some Bad actors were
allowed in the hen house so to speak
people like agent Kelo people like agent
kener in New York what is this about Sir
Cal please I need your help agent
Johnson your president your country
needs your
help you wanted to talk to me just
wanted to check in and see how you're
holding up I'm okay keeping busy so I
don't lose
myself sometimes it's easier to stay
focused on the task at hand so we can
complete the mission we need surgeons a
steady hand who can get the job done I
don't know how many people still fit
that description Cal oh I can think of
one you're steady Brian I think you may
be the surgeon I need to finally Exile
this tumor thank you for the vote of
confidence we never should have made her
an agent agent Kelo agent Lao she was in
the right place at the right time she
used her position to press her own
agenda I don't know what she's up to but
she is not interested in the continuity
of government
how else do you explain your Vendetta
against kener I can't explain it but I
want to help contain the damage they
could all do if you really want to help
Brian if you're ready to take back
control I've got a new assignment for
you but I need you to promise me you'll
keep an open mind and not believe
everything you've heard about Natalia
Sova like we heard in the final mission
there agent Johnson is all about getting
the mission done Cal is talking about
every other agent that has betrayed the
division but Johnson really wants to
believe Kela was responsible for doing
something wrong [__] he sounds like Me 2
years ago except without all the videos
Brian is an absolute Boy Scout and Cal
used this unwavering attitude and
loyalty to drive him into doing whatever
was asked of them so he made the perfect
head of a unit that would be used to
control the actions of certain shd
agents who may have strayed from their
mission let's just replay the message
from Brian Johnson at the beginning of
his fight scene that send the Healer for
extraction copy that agent this is it
hit them with everything you've
got system
ciled weak points
detected agent you know you're on the
wrong side of this war right we serve at
the pleasure of the president we work
for Homeland we work for cow it doesn't
matter if Isaac thinks you're on Mission
the minute you allied with El you went
rogue you think I'm evil because I'm a
Hunter we're the only ones still on
Mission if an agent steps out of line
we're here to clean up the
mess this single interaction has
confirmed so many different things that
we've been talking about over the months
and even years the hunters are agents
their job is to remove agents who have
gone off Mission agent Johnson wasn't
necessarily bad he was just following
his interpretation of the mission in a
different way to to us I touched on this
a few times through the Manhunt being
Rogue doesn't necessarily mean the same
thing as it used to regardless of how he
got there Cal could be the next in line
and even if he wasn't he's the most
senior member of leadership that we are
aware of that is still alive on the
other side we know how he got there and
what he's been doing with Natalia in the
Black Tusk but technically we're not
reporting to anyone we're the rebels in
this
situation so where do I think everything
is going from here well we know that
season 3 is going to be back in New York
and given how often her name has been
brought up through this Mission and
season Calo was likely to play a
prominent role there have been a ton of
accusations being thrown at her
accusations that people like myself have
been dishing out for years but if I was
a bidding man I would say that the only
thing she'll be proven guilty of in the
upcoming season is that she is young and
a little bit
chaotic this season started at a
relatively moderate Pace some SAR to
previous ones but by the end we learned
more than the last couple of Seasons
combined with birdie now rescued we know
more about Natalia's goals and the Black
Tusk infrastructure than ever before
however I get the feeling that we'll be
having a small break from progressing
the story arc named Vanguard season 3
will have us going back to New York
Vanguard being Aaron keena's call sign
we will be discovering more about what
our favorite antagonist was about
leading up to his death at the end of
Warlords of New York on top of this I
believe we'll be hearing more about what
agent Calo has been up to and why she
left DC for New York this has been a
compilation of year five season 2 if
you've made it this far I hope you've
been able to follow as there's been a
lot playing out this season but just
sing out in the comments if you have any
questions thank you very much for
watching and extremist Mullis extremer
[Music]
[Applause]
media
[Music]